what's going on everybody this is mike
of munch development coming to you with
another coding tech
original without further ado let's get
started so today we're going to be
discussing
10 helpful vs code extensions for html
and css all right so let's get right to
it the most popular one
right you need to see your html you want
a hot reload
what's the best one to go with the only
one right the top dog
it's live server all right so i'm to
enable it
right i've had it for years now but i'm
going to enable it
what you're going to see happen down
here is i'm going to get this button
here at the bottom
i click it to go live and i get
a fresh well let's just move this over
here
there we go now it's it it reloaded at
the bottom but i want it to be right
here so i'm just going to refresh that
it went down to the monitor below but
we're just going to work with this one
all right
so we've got our live server it does hot
reloading i'm going to hit up uh alt
shift down arrow and yeah
all right so we got a bunch of these now
i hit save and
it automatically hot reloaded okay so
let's go
back here i'm gonna get rid of this line
um
ten points for anybody that can tell me
uh where this text comes from all right
so to number two okay so we're back
uh we're gonna do auto rename tag all
right we're gonna install
auto rename tag okay so i've installed
it already
but you can just go here if you're
searching for extensions you just come
up here you search for it
and you click install but i have most of
these installed already so i'm just
gonna enable them
all right so i'm enabling you know what
yeah so auto rename tag let me disable
it first
sorry i'm supposed to show you what life
was like before
all right so if i wanted to rename this
tag here let me scroll all the way down
and say well i want this to be an h1 i'd
have to go here
find the first one and then find the
second one and then
i'm going to reload that again so we can
oh sorry i need to do that i wanted to
do live
server there you go go live all right so
let's just refresh that and now we've
got we all are tall
is here as an h1 now if i wanted to do
that for all of these
you know the first one then the last one
the opening tag closing tag
that would get a little cumbersome all
right in comes
auto rename tag let's enable it all
right
so let's say i wanted to uh rename this
tag now
oh you see it's what's happening it's
doing part of the work for me
right let's see i want to make this an
h3 all right
yeah oh wait n3 that's not good h3
there you go browser's like i don't know
what to do with that all right
so we got auto rename tag all right
the next one it's really important it's
not just for html and css
it's for pretty much any language that
you're writing and you're using vs
visual studio code or any
uh text editor you need
prettier okay let's just get that out of
the way right now you can see how my
my code is all over the place even in my
css file
it's sort of all over the place and
that's on purpose but you can uh
prior to prettier and eslint and all
these other things
you'd have to deal with you'd have to
deal with all sorts of people's
all preferences when it came to how
people formatted their code well not
with prettier
all right so let's enable prettier and
see what happens so if i click save
nothing's going to happen all right so
nothing's happening so what that what do
i need to do about that
i need to go into my settings i'm going
to hit command then
and i'm going to format on save
all right and i'm going to say yes i
want the editor to format on save
okay now i can come here and click save
and look what happens it formats my css
and it'll do the same thing for my html
prettier
for the win all right so the next one
that we're going to use
is intellisense for css class names in
html that's this one right here
okay so basically it allows for
intellisense
all right uh for your uh local and
for uh external uh uh
style sheets okay so let's enable it all
right so let's see well at first let's
do this all right so i'm going to go
over here
go to main.css let's say i wanted to
make this i want to take this class and
i'm going to use this so we all
are small and i wanted to say and i do
that
and i say okay well let's just see
nothing's happening so i just have to
paste this in i don't know if it works
hey but it does right so you see what
happens over here on live server
it updates all right but wouldn't it be
nice to know what's in my main.css well
that's where intellisense where css
classes comes in
let's enable it and now when i type
a class and then i hit control space oh
wait it's not it's not there it is
all right hit control space i can pick
from
the um the classes that are in
any uh imported style sheet all right so
if i said small
let's say i hit that uh it's not
actually not working for control space
i think that um i think that's for ex
i'm gonna show you in a second i think
that's for external style sheets that
you bring in
so let's say i'm bringing large okay so
large
right we've got it going okay so what if
i wanted to
use a bootstrap all right i'm going to
bring this link in over here
how can i make how can i make that work
for a uh
a library that i pull in cdn uh from
bootstrap right
so i can command shift p all right and
then i'll say
cache css class definitions so if i were
to was
were to do that now uh and i would say
class
command space nothing would really show
up right but
what i want to do is i come back over
here command shift p and i say
cache css class definitions so it's
going to cache
those definitions from bootstrap and now
when i hit command
space let's see come on there we go
we've got all of this stuff to win so if
you know text
uh what is it alert or something like
that alert
danger right that should change that up
there right the alert
is now danger right so my bootstrap is
working i can use my bootstrap classes
now
um just by hitting um command space and
it'll intelli
intellisense will say like okay what is
this uh
let's see is it yeah it's not even
needing command space
i think command space was something that
we're using in the past but it doesn't
use it anymore so
we're going to go ahead and say never
mind i don't need it right but
look at this button outline success i
don't know what that's going to do it's
probably not going to just you're going
to change it to green okay cool
all right so we got our whatever
language you whatever
css framework you like you can just
import it and you can have
access to those style sheets all right
so let's keep moving
right along all right so that was number
four number five
is css peak all right css peak allows
you to
uh if you're clicking here uh you wanted
to uh
option click but i'll show you like
right now i don't know what these
classes actually do
like my large class what does it do i
don't know but we can install
uh csspeak and let's
enable it all right and then we come
back over here and we can click
all right we click that well let's go
back here sorry i got my emacs stuff on
all right and let's do uh peak right
and we say peak definition right and
it's like oh
okay cool i know what that large text is
now right
okay uh what the large class is i can do
i can figure that out right so and then
your um
your peak definition is uh looks like
that's uh
option f12 all right let's check to see
what that see if that works option f12
and i think i have to yeah option f12
and it works okay cool
all right and i think you can also
option
click you can yeah you can command you
can command click it as well
and it goes straight to it okay cool all
right so
let's open our main backup okay cool we
got that back over there all right
this document is not the prettiest thing
going on but we're working on it all
right
so we've got cssp now one thing that i
really like as i'm uh
as i'm using more grid layouts uh is i
i've come to like
let's see this i'm going to bring this
over here and come back in here and
we'll do
uh css grid snippets okay
so let's where is it where is that bad
boy there it is css grid snippets right
so you can actually uh
use these uh snippets here and it allows
you to do kind of quick
uh css grid stuff right um so i'm going
to
let's see pull it in and i'm gonna i'm
new to this one
though right this is not something that
i've been using very often so
i want to be using some of these and
let's say okay well let's let's make
uh let's look at these while looking at
uh
yeah so this one's a new one to to your
boy here all right so
if i wanted to add here let's see let's
see some of the um some of the
possibilities so let's say dg
right display grid all right so if i
have all right let's see uh
grid and i want to say i want to say dg
display grid uh let's see uh gtr
grid template rows okay cool repeat i
need uh
seven rows at one fr okay and let's go
back over to my html and see what i can
do
i can say uh dot grid
emit uh you gotta use my image right and
then come back over here
and see what happens all right to my
html over here
all right let's see all right did i do
display grid
yeah display grid grid template rules
repeat one fr
okay well that did not work oh you know
what i'm thinking the wrong thing
columns there we go all right boom
see there we go that's what i was
expecting to see all right let me scroll
down over here all right so you have
five
columns across there we go one two three
four five and then it
hops back down and makes it look okay
cool so this is a pretty cool one
i like it i've been using it kind of
sparingly but i'm going to use it more
and more often i just want to drop that
one in here though
because i think it's a pretty cool one
especially if you're going to be using
more modern css grid type stuff
all right so to the next one all right
let's see where
what we got uh csx flexbox number seven
css flexbox cheat sheet okay
uh this is very helpful for me i like
this one
where is it uh yeah yeah cs oh yeah i
have an install i need to reinstall this
one right
i was looking it up and i like what it
does right
so for those of us who do not remember
everything at all times let me close
this out
you can look at this one you can say
okay look here's a cheat sheet
we can do command shift p right and
search for open css flex box
all right so we can do that okay command
k on this i like that command k
all right so let's do uh command kk
all right and you can see the css
flexbox cheat sheet and it kind of gives
you a visual view
a visual of what like what each flex
uh property does right and some of the
you know the properties and then all of
the um
the the uh descriptors and the
properties so you can see like row row
reverse what does it do
right you can kind of play around with
this and see what will happen you know
direction left to right
and things like that so this is it's not
something that actually
you use in your code it's not helping
you to code faster but it is something
that
when you get confused you're like why is
my code not working the way i want it to
work
well especially if it's flexbox you can
come over here and look at this flex
cheat sheet
and it will help you to kind of get an
idea of where you might have gone wrong
all right
so uh number eight all right number
eight
number eight is lorem ipsum right it's
very i i mean it's not the
greatest but it's very helpful when you
need to create
uh let's do this do a p and we do lorem
5 3000 all right and then i click save
and i come back over here right and i've
got my 3 000 words of text and i can see
what it looks like right
lorem i've been using for years it is
very helpful
so i don't have to you know make a bunch
of garbage text and just like you know
asdf asdf asdf right
like eventually that that gets a little
boring okay so
um let's go let's number what we got
number
let's see number nine yes number nine
all right this one is more of a visual
help
but it's vs code icons or material icon
theme so it's a two for one
all right you can pick the one that you
like the best okay so
i i i go back and forth
what's going on oh that's because i have
that in there all right so i go back and
forth between which one i like
of the two of these so vs code icon so
let's look at the icons here right these
are your default icons right
you come over here you say you know what
i want to enable uh vs code icons
because i like those better
right let's see what happens so i'm
going to reload
and see what happens well it didn't
change much okay
let's see what happens all right maybe
maybe
maybe let me try uh material icon themes
all right enable
all right let's go over here there that
changed all right so you see the
material icon themes changed
i don't know why vs code icons did not
change probably because that's the
default
probably icons for visual studio let's
see
maybe they look exactly the same look
let's check let's check it out
let's see well you know
it didn't work so we'll uh we'll disable
that one all right so go with the
material i contain no i'm joking you
could pick which one
but it allows you to see all of these
types right so
um either material icon theme or visual
studio code
icons all right it gives you a visual
cue as to what type of file you're
dealing with
um i know i i it's become so second
nature for me
that i i rely on this right you can go
minimalist you can you can get rid of
all of those in your settings
uh let's see uh let's see we're just
going to do that
icons icons yeah
preferences icon themes like you can
pick which one you want
right uh you can go none material
minimal
seti visual and vs code icons there you
go all right so that's how you pick
between preferences icon themes right
always go to your preferences
all right material yeah you can pick one
right uh you can minimal
right that's like that's just that's
where the weird uh
i mean hey minimal if you like
minimalist right you know
um yeah that's the basics right there
and then
uh i twitch again i switch between these
two some sometimes i like
one sometimes like the other i'll just
switch it up every now and then all
right
so that was number nine all right number
10
is and i'm gonna make this one quick
okay
this is for virtually anyone that's
using git
okay so if you have a project and you
need to make sure that
oh you need to know who made changes
that you know possibly broke something
or someone had a really great idea and
you're like hey
i like this idea who who did it all
right so i'm going to do a git init
all right so i initialized an empty
repository and i'm going to install
git lens right so i'm going to enable
this
and what happens is i'm eventually going
to get so i'm going to do this i'm going
to do git
uh commit minus m uh
initial commit
all right untracked file sorry git add
dot i'm going to add everything
and then i'm going to do initial commit
all right and then i'm going to make a
change okay so i'm like hey
so but actually it's showing me already
right here saying you
made these checks uh changes seconds ago
and the uh commit uh message was initial
commit
right so i can go to this uh and look at
the initial commit three files added
you know i can take a look at that but
it's initially is letting me see who
made the changes
and who i need to yell at right so i
need to yell at myself okay
so i think that's it that's all 10 right
um let me know down in the comments
below uh html css
um extensions that you use that you find
helpful
uh let me know if you uh enjoyed this
video uh don't forget to uh
like comment subscribe to the channel uh
you'll see the uh the code
uh in the description i'm not sure if
you want to see this little code but
uh if you if you know where this text is
from uh yeah right
if you remember if you know what book
this text is from uh you'll get 10
points i don't know what my point system
is my point system is useless
but it'd be a fun exercise to try to
figure out where this is from
uh and what would you all like to see
next so comment below
uh in the video uh thanks for all the
comments that you've been uh
leaving uh it's really helping me to
improve my pedagogical still
skill right i'm learning and growing as
a teacher
and i also you know i want to make sure
that i'm giving you content
that's helpful for you all right we
can't help everybody but we want to help
as many as we can so i will see you all
on the next one
and happy coding